et si tu m'as trahi mais t'as de beaux
yeux tu sais embrasse-moi allait bien
non j'ai plus envie
tu es tu as tu sais toi là toi tu as
tout ce qu'il faut tu vois et en plus où
il faut aller en place monoplaces -
ouais tu veux ou tu veux prendre un
temps fou plein la vue tu as beau joe
oliver allemagne e mail faisait alors ma
chérie tu me reconnais c'est pas ta
culotte en chocolat tons caramel mon
tendon joue du sucre est allé marché
libyen dans mac os x est belle ray ban
s'est pas démentie benhari
la baule yeux tu sais moi oui d'accord
mais pas ici
bon je chéris et canton de vaud s'engage
au plus ok c'est bon
monsieur tu sais à 10h10 aurait pas
mieux
t'as de beaux yeux tu sais dès minuit
fait sur wii
est ce que je veux me marier avec toi
c'est toi c'est toi encore le pape avec
la maman pas moi c'est toi marié à les
petites femmes de paris tout les mêmes
le grand jour bonjour mademoiselle on
vous avez les jolies qui comme la sig au
lien vous avez des deux jolis ballons
d'avancé vous avez la tête de poulet
ok t'as d'beaux yeux tu sais
c'est terminé molénat moi j'aimerais
vraiment terminée sur le jeu c'est vrai
je sais ce que je fais moi les filles
affaire allait bien george morris